the structure today is more than 1200
feet above sea level so how could this
place be the location of an island that
once met the ocean well
notice the various areas of white
coloration that you see not only from
the air but from satellite imagery as
well
these white blemishes are indeed salt
something many people do not know is
that this region has an abundance of
salt at surface level in fact you can
read articles about the salt caravans
that exist in mauritania today
this is something that is widely
documented yet little known this salt
came from the ocean and you can
literally see it in the exact areas
where cataclysmic flooding once flowed
through here as you can see from
satellite imagery and even the areas of
the lowest elevation within the wrist
shot are the areas with the most salt
making it even more evident that salt
water once consumed and settled within
this structure and you'll also see it
noticeably at the southern entrance
respectively we can even reference the
nearby to sheets mauritania salt
caravans i shared a few moments ago
all of those white blemishes are surface
level salt again this is how you know
the wrist shot was consumed by the ocean
within the last 12 thousand years by
some unknown cataclysmic flooding event
which indicates that something else
something separate happened over this
area far more recently
and the fact that these landmark water
ripples still exist in the same fashion
as the identical rip ripples in
washington state only further adds to
the corresponding evidence that
something happened over the wrist shot
at that same period of time
and these features of water erosion
would have surely been eroded long ago
especially when we consider that the
sahara is confirmed to transition back
and forth from lush green jungle to
desert every twenty thousand years